[Music]
spend two weeks sorry you had to go
watch what legal legends are what happen
is watching the dota at the
International
[Music]
- cutscene on the way to China so we
made sure yeah
[Music]
okay I'm gonna invite you so you're on
pip right not yet
oh it's still our faces so what happened
last time while you and while you
remember what was happening while you
you recount what was happening okay I'm
thinking
I remember the train situation we were
on a train and there was aa Me's we met
a guy but then I think he died
we had to go to China Oh a booby lady
she had red but she damn it she was
killed
we've met a lot of people and killed
them I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't know why we're going to join us I
kind of forgot myself oh hi why China
should we change it to it's still you
know it's been you know we've been on
phone screen for a while now Leon is
looking in the window of the airplane
okay good
no not explained imagine if I was
Chinese in space I just explained the
cutscenes
isn't his hair grows longer you hold
Robbie it does no why didn't you turn me
in
you could have cleared your name I love
you maybe but it wouldn't stop Simmons
besides you started to grow me a little
bit also
be remiss if I didn't mention it's our
like your anniversary freaking evil
today isn't it it is I got an update on
Facebook that said it's been a year
since you posted this would you like to
share a memory is he laughing my screen
shouldn't be black right this is the
second time no this is the second time
in this series that pilots have taken
off why is my speed back I don't know is
it broken
I don't know hon over
is it going oh it's back I'm here okay
good because I'm not doing well Elena
oh god help
coming visit me huh Stillman boozing
did we get a Magnum is that what's
happening oh yeah
the lightning Hawk so gross
he's so gross
yeah he's got a lot of butts it's all
whole so happy can even convert happy
anniversary listen I think something's
wrong with the plane
should it be tilting like that why is
everyone wearing the same suit oh is
this gonna be the same [ __ ] where
they all become zombo's these guys this
guy just oh [ __ ] just woke up hammered
drank too many G and T's on the way here
well I don't feel great these guys are
all wearing the same suit these two guys
are the same person look at this wait
this is like when you were really in the
magnificent into the fruit cake remember
you kept like looking at that plane zigs
we got a zag is this airforce one party
passenger 57 oh there's a plant in here
an herb plant your ru is where over here
my voice down low or just I'm good - you
may be able to my headphones I think
it's okay oh [ __ ]
this reminds me of the the gang beef
Boggs this reminds me of snakes on a
plane
have you seen the gang beats Boggs yeah
oh it's on the episode I when they all
try to drink 70 beers what do you know
what do now cat phoner us it I fell on
the ground
I got it there's guy with a bunch of
butt holes in here so I hope you thought
toilet paper Dan you got sick outfit
yeah it was this purple it was a nice
color shirt I'll be the mail today oh we
both gotta do this one you need double
help yeah hey girls is this us notice
the cutscene
pretty belabor one like I don't think
time did that happen to you too
what does that help do he's also funny
but he's so shiny you know
what hatch what do I do
already the same thing oh you got a one
of us has to yeah go into this box shoot
him or distract him while I do this
you're like Burma way not too far up no
no he's coming all right
I tried shooting him in the butt smart I
[Music]
shot him what's going on oh you're dead
oh you just get covered in butts and
then one day you are but there's not a
lot to say about this being sequence
besides it's not interesting alright so
when he gets to this one you open it I'm
gonna [ __ ] call the
shut up can you knock me on the ground
all right here we got that okay watch
out he just is like defending this hat
all right don't fight yeah he sucks all
right here you go to the hatch I'll lure
him over here I'm gonna shoot this thing
and stun him okay
I'll shoot him in the Wiener in the
Wiener but oh wait are you [ __ ] hurt
again no all right do it
oh that one's already shot I'm gonna do
my best
he's the Magnum nonono-chan he's gonna
get me maybe no I'm dead
the hatch is open sorry
I'll call my proctologist hey sorry
it gave me eight so I was we're over -
yeah I was trying to sauce it's a quick
time of it
no I know yeah you press it too early
and I press it all right I'll go to
school go to the hatch got it
get off my plane
the obvious reference and I'm not gonna
not go for it
I'll try two three maybe
oh my god this is hitting our two as
well we're gonna have to move this is
just on track three kind of what does
that say about uncharted 3 there's a lot
of putts in that game too
[Music]
for a but he flew pretty good but can
fly was it am i a pilot now those are
weapon in here
[ __ ] skill points hey check it out
in other news a plane went down over new
york full of 5000 skill points is there
stuff in here too I'm gonna mix those
right now alright should probably do
that to know there's an Emily did you
shoot that yes that's why I did that I
saw the emblem then I was aware that
there was other stuff
oh no guess what
more gas everyone's a zombie now we all
saw this coming
sorry sorry that's my bad
I came here to join the mile-high club
and kill zombies I don't have a penis
well I hope you like not having a skull
NATO Emma what's that OS already every
time time I seen NATO amyloid your
tornado
tiny little tornados come out of your
gun we both felt you forgot to wear your
seat belt sir the seat belt line the
seat belt sign is clearly on sit the
[ __ ] down
are you allowed to use incendiary
grenades on airplanes I don't think
there's much to the game's physics or
rules so I would say go for it well [ __ ]
do we get out of here oh I see we gotta
press this is this a wing or a fuselage
part of the fuselage oh god that guy's
not behind us is me it's hard to tell
because they sound stupid
I'm all grenade now yes I'm all I'm all
NATO go down here can I throw a grenade
Oh today Oh
wait a minute
wonder how long we get stand here
whether we can stay here forever in the
plane would never crash you don't only
these two knew that they would not don't
you don't know that this is the kind of
game where's my key when you need him oh
[Music]
wait why does the guy have to be the
pilot oh [ __ ] I gotta sit on these for
me me oh they got guns too third button
in the fourth row ah there's a lot of
them they look like Joe meringue I
really like I had green hair pull the
leveller how's things going over there
it is harder than it looks
I can't believe that this shape the
trick to flying a plane is hitting
square and X at the same time hey what
should you warp back here I swear
comical
take the fly this thing several put a
joke how many zombies it takes a storm a
cockpit
this thing is so wide it Tom yeh gaining
attitude
or enjoy hey did he just see her yes
he's got excellent vision but he doesn't
know how to pull up on lovers yeah I
feel like that should kill the plan this
is a much more depressing not
oscar-worthy version of sully instead of
landing on the Hudson II land and I'm
Beijing or every are searching for
partner well you're out I don't want to
wait 50 seconds it's fine you can do
what we did last time and cancel it and
invite me right in that's dumb maybe it
works itself out sometimes it does
hopefully this happened when we were
doing those uh the puzzles with the
statues of the crossbows I remember that
they were back to the beginning kind of
it doesn't look like the beginning no
serious so was I gotta fight that tire
oh is that oh I thought that was I
thought that was the princess lady
what's her name the president's daughter
I'm not sure I thought it was Ivanka all
this chief security adviser Simmons
Shari Bergen and Jake Wescoe that's the
campaign we might not play he's your
supervisor way to meet with him right
now
I know what we're about to do I need to
know back off bro bro bro bro bro bro
your brothers will avoid contact enough
six-car bro
oh it's [ __ ] tyrant nemesis whatever
it is
somebody save her from that flying
engine named an idiot Leon you did that
on purpose
hey is that a nemesis kind of yeah haha
bro
we're not bros bro who think that guy
likes us yeah what's the plan
ah shoot him while Jake stands in the
middle of the oh god he turbinate run
run run run rally so he threw grenade
yeah a lot of NATO ammo the tornados
gone
what's the goal am I using all my good
ammo on purpose always coming up come
out back shout - I'm gonna throw a
grenade
welcome to nate town I think we're just
shooting him a lot
why is he keep doing a thing he's so
stupid
oh there's ammo crates on top of her
some of these containers Oh take it from
us this guy is indestructible yeah hell
out of here you couldn't have told us
that before we wasted half our ammo
seriously Jake I'm not playing your
campaign because of that why don't we
just do that forever any man we all yeah
those so sick
the guys I'm Megaman Buster cannon marry
don't leave me with him he's a jerk
go to their side damn it came to our
side what the hell uh-huh what am i
doing shotgun um I don't know what [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you keep running little guy you got it
okay I got stuff all right here we go
hold on hold on hold on sherry here we
go yeah drive a bus into him I'm gonna
try
are you hot-wiring a bus listen oh okay
it's red to blue Hotwire it got it hot
guy hookup guys always call wire oh we
gotta climb up
oh yeah sure up here I take it
can i push this off oh I think we were
supposed to do that a while ago he's
missing a hand
no watts you just attach that to a crane
it just happened to be there that was
pretty cool
carries around to spare yeah I agree
that is really hard to believe that's
what they choose to be so now what his
plans walking anal glands don't
surprising but
I think he tried to kill that oh no I
fell down so I'm still up here but I
don't know that I'm supposed to be oh
wait yeah no wait you want to be on that
side thank come over this way mommy got
scary he might he's Mike tell me your
name I'm sure damn well he's got both of
you yes you guys look so dumb
yeah okay I'm out oh I'm dead I know I'm
not good hold on a second
I [ __ ] up my quick time okay cool I
got out
you know what this situation needs okay
are these things here will eat them over
here Derek thought these things kill him
those barrels thought we'd do something
with that tower fairly serving there
right over you do the barrel thing okay
grenade dumb dumb idiots oh that's what
did it
Brees had to wait that out
I'm so disappointed you guys see that
who's Jerry you made that up don't trust
that guy with you oh don't feel really
good about him we got really good are
you okay I can't pick an easy [ __ ]
Thanks
Oh Yuri said she was meeting Simmons in
the coal lung building the first thing
you're gonna need to do is cut through
the outdoor market up ahead you got it
there's a chicken poor little chickens
they're gonna die in there oh [ __ ]
this is the famous scene isn't it this
is the one that puts you in the fan
isn't it
I don't remember I'm pretty sure I think
this is the one where you're not really
supposed to fight them you're supposed
to like hide form or something Jesus
this is based on very little pigs are
not supposed to do that I'm never eating
bacon again looks like a regenerator
president trying to keep it out yoo-hoo
guys [ __ ] the roads that's a new
trick it's like no time to be funny
alright so do you want to split up sure
okay that works going for the key on the
left
good luck to all of us God have mercy on
our soon already okay I found a key oh
no I'm being cornered by them alright I
got out splitting up as a bad you know
it's fine I got a no consequences this
lock - what are you going for middle or
right I don't know I know we need to
open the o open door can you use that
key now oh I don't know whenever mine's
going this way go this way and somewhere
this way do everyone well this is locked
- I'm going coop on my face come on whoa
oh okay alright I got electrocuted turn
this lever down make this lever flaccid
if you don't I mean I don't
oh he's on my body
do their [ __ ] supergirls well you're
lucky you he like ran at me okay these
guys are regenerating like like hotcakes
listen they're [ __ ] hopping on each
other and hotcakes
okay okay grenades natal oh great
I own a them this is the time for hahaha
grenade right quick this door circled
now got it keep going that way I think
okay I don't know how else to get to the
other one it's okay it's worth it yeah
the other one this is long as well how
about lifting this okay we have a bit of
time
good job can I shut it here maybe how in
tarnation is gonna get to that key huh
you start c4 uh you mean those things
when people step on them
yes you mean a set some some trees apps
still isn't opening Oh what sorry a
little bit back here a hand is jumping
at me yeah you can pick them up and
chuck them like hand frizzies let me
open this do dedo okay okay I'm getting
there yeah what's going on here
can't break those right here can break
things
we're obviously missing something super
obvious and we're yeah
is this something where we like are
supposed to crawl or go back to this
room where we go I'm I used our keys and
put them in the door bit [ __ ] I put a
bomb out there where back in the freezer
oh I put a c4 in there so watch out
do it up awesome I thought it went off
when they touched it
no see for his remote hideaway did it
there's a herb back here in a box with
skill points huh but there's some dead
fish
we're obviously missing something really
obvious and it's very frustrating
probably for the viewers to bear with us
weird you know we know where this is
going that way really [ __ ] hand
something I can shoot that would be nice
that's always simple and clean and
effective I can't open this door can you
you know what maybe it's a thing where
you throw me oh that makes sense coming
or there's a lever somewhere I'm just
not oh I'm [ __ ] dumb there's a ladder
I don't know if this is it though
this is it this is it I'm coming
how'd you get over there okay
there's a ladder guy yet oh god I do you
need to heal I how do I put don't go
back there
move away move away this way for me okay
skadoosh oh [ __ ]
sorry anything I'll kill this guy
alright so I gotta check you over there
are you ready go come on hurry up cow ah
[ __ ] alright so you do that and I'll do
this I'm not sure what I'm supposed to
be doing
am I just supposed to jump how's it
going on your end about to get the key I
think
I thought how is it down there was oh I
see I'm gonna oh I need you to get over
here son oh I got an unlock one of these
doors I'll be there come I'm coming over
here okay
hi come on come on why is the only thing
glitch writing in the wall that says
strawberry's right there
I hope we both need to kick open this
door hey watch out
okay quick door circle okay [ __ ] you
who's that who's almost oh I'm dead no I
got you happy University [ __ ] I'll get
the key you kill them hey watch these
guys I got the key let's get out of here
run run run run run run what if that
song came on something something
merry-go-round I just I know the O'Hara
see that's I think the only reason
anyone knows man I'm just constantly
switching topic on inside put him in a
fan
[Music]
who wants a smoothie hit frappe needs
more banana just in time for my weekly
protein shake
odda she's wearing different clothes ADA
I suspect a conversation where they go
what's going on and she goes I'll tell
you later
all will be revealed later
meet me at midnight under the Ravens
gaze
I'd love that her reflexes not to just
take cover its to use it's got some
answers
wait hold on what's okay if there's no
loot you have to eat your shirt looks
like one of us can go low and one of us
can go high what was you what would you
prefer are you sure that's gonna be
locked just find another way through why
do we have to sprint I don't know but
I'm not with you I can see up your skirt
huh God get ready to press the button
what is it Oh God there is no quick time
that just kills you it really hurt me
Oh there's like alcoves um I don't know
actually what the [ __ ] I'm dead yep
sorry I think I'm I don't know what to
do about it
oh you know what yeah do that sure I'm
coming oh hey there's a copy sorry no
it's my fault
I don't know why I assumed it would be a
QuickTime event in this game of all yeah
what a silly decision
remember resmio for you were doing that
yeah I just make the assumption that
it's dumb
little did we know they want to use our
sick ass acrobatic is is like if you
want to use a game mechanic you should
have like required to use it as a
previous time right yeah like something
that would be like oh it's this thing
again
there's been no assumption that we were
going to ever use this add lasers yeah
beautiful
[ __ ] how's this one working i what the
[ __ ]
wait get over here yeah yeah yeah yep
good job wait did you just see that what
oh it was Chris and peers it's their
campaigns meeting up with us you see
that yes I thought the game [ __ ] up
and like made us look like them for a
second that would have been disturbed
again assuming the game is being dumb
maybe you just like become them and then
it's their campaign so many stairs what
does that what does oo mean what's right
oh no great coming oh oh what's boo
beans every load everything I possibly
can while I'm here there's a message in
my Cheerios it's oh oh my god what the
[ __ ] my Froot Loops said the same thing
my Applejack said the same thing
my SpaghettiOs told me the same thing
alright stop thinking of my doughnuts
spelled that I saw a car that for those
things that one's not even food-related
with my hair just by no we're just going
for food ever yeah the whole joke was
about food in the shape of Oz why can't
i Johnny's I mean my onion rings I do
there you go you're back you're back
locked locked locked I've milena has a
very subtle boob jiggle that should not
be happening she's not don't don't you
release that liquid ada these things
shoot them
oh that looks so funny for my [ __ ] up
my [ __ ] but I'm sure she'll tell us
later do we have to shoot them back into
the red you take care of that well you
know we're doing we're shooting them
over to Christmas here right now
oh are we hey Kristen Pierce don't you
know we're trying to beat this game if
that's the game you're playing I'm
playing a I phone did I do it I should
have done it you gotta do it again it's
not room 0 through room yeah
hey there's stuff in here money money
money
points skill points I have no clue what
time we started well we promised people
an extra long episode so let's just play
until we die probably Circle
are you thinking I'm thinking suicide
pact at charge power bottom smoke does
she's taping them bad apple cinnamon
flavor Rancic just shot a time running
on my screen and she like it's like a
gazelle hi how'd you get ahead of me I'm
faster you got it there she is cut her
off she's got a back all you idiots
she's gonna totally Batclaw out of there
shoot her back love
shooter briefcase
wait why did I do that I'm conflicted
with my own character here what are you
doing here
put your gun down Chris she's a key
witness we need her witness she's the
one who did all this
no it wasn't her it was Simmons the
national security advisor I also might
make the cover I lost over 70 thousand
people putting the president because of
Simmons
she's working for do you know what that
means
why couldn't they just agree to like
shoot her in like a non kill area like
Annie or something that's what I would
do her heart's like that I'll admit it
was pretty epic Plains for first time
when VCU come face to face it has more
meaning now I'll tell you that she's
gonna back law she
nice job here's Jesus that sucks
how many do your job be SAS soldiers
does it take to lose a Batclaw girl suck
he's the one I have to play as
[Music]
alright bsaa we'll handle later you take
care of Simmons like a mirsini shot
is what I think is hurt a lot apparently
like she wouldn't be back long anywhere
if he shot her in the knee you know she
could tutor in the hand
all right both hands so now he's just
letting Chris go after her
what's fine so you shoot her in both
hands and then she can't claw away
stigmata
where Derek you jerk oh we wrong way no
she could just take it ease their back
law lady oh are you really sure you're
okay with this a targeted Simmons always
has been then why were we following that
girl so aggressively like obviously we
want ADA like it's digging stuff right
here too
is this something where I throw you over
I'm just blind why the camera lifts up
like that did you happen to you - yep -
show us that skyscraper we're probably
gonna go there soon
trains again our arch-nemesis well
that's the guys in the plane again
mercy me shots would solve this kindly
take these two into custody
won't you they said you were involved in
the terrorist attack is it true what are
they running down the street screaming
it to anyone who listen it's for the
benefit of the United States and global
security can't see how killing the
president is good for country well we
have Liam to thank for that
dispose of them she had the right she'd
like the time to say no how many more
times Jake after crabber toast you were
still of use to us you you are super
dumb you think you can make it to that
door why don't we just waste them
because I need you to take care of
sherry can we wrap this up I do have
better things to do what was he doing up
there I don't want to say anything but
some people think you need them get you
some protection
it's not how gunfights were heard
outside go [ __ ] dard you're nuts
you're crazy man that's a huge dart she
got me she got me
who knew that stop standing like and a
very high height surrounded by goons
oh my god
train fight scene also inspired mama
bought the Polar Express my gears of war
like ROM yes like the ultimate battle
shut up you've said that several times
no you're not because like literally
every time you guys say that you're
gonna end it it continues I really want
this let's go
but I want this red herb I have to first
dates crazy Wow you just circle me I'll
fight him wait here good luck I think we
both could have made that jump to the
leg there is no doubt in my mind
we've got you unless you plan on
becoming a monster in the next 20
seconds prepare to die
and he disclosed the truth behind
Raccoon City the US would have lost all
its authority and the global political
order would Derek is not lead is one
possible disaster you create and that's
what kind of looks like Steve Buscemi
his bolo tie is dancing look at it I was
born this way stop that stop being on
fire
right he's a lion now some kind of
muscle
[Applause]
yeah what
we're too close let's move God wait
where what what no damn you
we have to hear that zinger before we
jump down chute a ship mega-magnet get
off the ground your stomach meat do you
know what this is the time for Ralph
knit
I like the way
everybody go oh my god
he's above us Oh maybe even like that's
just like you're alone it's Oh course
it's not oh I found him grenade
so maybe lift me up and I'll go on top
come back this way okay and then lift me
up I think and then yeah
wait there's a red arbitrator yeah
Circle here and then I'll go up top and
come back down outside oh so you'll open
the door for me I see up here now do I
should I give you it I guess
yeah I guess you've got to get we got to
shoot him until he becomes a dude again
and then run by him oh no no now go back
down go back down where you just came
from why because we gotta get on both
sides of him down there so go but I the
door shut where can I just open it my
dumb
go all the way to the end alright here
we go
ha no what the hell what what do you
want I don't know
come on check this out do you want from
me stay down there for now just this
door is locked
yeah yeah I stay on there for now yeah I
can't jump this so if you come to the
other side
and you can let me up ok go to where I
am [ __ ] I'm alright number here okay so
we got away from to come up and then
just get on either side of him I guess I
so shoot him and I won't even come -
dude run by him
oh ok now stay here stand toward the
side let him come up between us ok I
guess that's what they seem to be
implying yeah
okay we're on both sides I'm on his weak
side kick butt side and looking right at
me
yeah he's home in yeah
and so aroused yeah yeah okay Brad where
am I going
thanks Deb here I guess [ __ ] him up hit
him from behind your turn
d-dad
yeah yep yep pom-pom hump him
yummy a jump on top of him he's not dead
no way oh my god
[Music]
we well obviously
reunite oh my god
then I could use some help that's right
I'm Debbie en are you okay just
bitch-slapped then make some kind of
hand signal if you're okay I can't
really shoot my thing I was going well I
can't really [ __ ] see look at this
like I have no visual I'm shooting him
now wait Mikey why can't I
I hate the camera run I guess it's a
[ __ ] horse now with like it's
shooting that it's being done
can we crouch down
what am i doing on it I know I can't
afford it
oh [ __ ] I stopped [ __ ] up but a long
arm of the law what are we doing
I like super confused shooting it and
those plus tools on top
oh there's Posterous looks like it I'm
actually yeah she goes things seem to be
reacting poorly to my bullets it's like
sushi
shoot it face shoot him the mouth oh did
you do it no yes
Beijing's gorgeous this time of night
it's it could it could be like a little
cooler like a degree a degree or two
cooler yep yep yep yep yep yep yep yep
yep
yes she did I guess all right done
this trains fine them continue to shoot
him at least a mirsini shot you're
really hung up on the knee cappings
capam me captain cab him in his ass
have you ever seen the chocolate syrup
on your ice cream that becomes a shell
and then cracks pretty good
I was punching stuff hey eyeball eyeball
eyeball
this lion hoist time to change and some
kind of mutated my horse now I'm just
doing
what's the motivation for running to the
other side of the Train
they definitely would've right there's
no way you threw out that you could
thread it difficult
ah it's Mikey no nevermind that's not
like you why that clothes for water
you guys okay didn't need to tell us
head for the mission objective when we
didn't see it yes I don't do I look like
I know I don't know yeah but we did what
we could
let's go I look like [ __ ] we're so slow
this is I hate when they do that it's
called narrative pay off no when it
gained momentum no favorite no that's is
that the boo saw that's like narrative
slug it's the bow saw
it's where it just what is the basalt
doing in Shanghai slurms long and like
doesn't have any value I think
it's over
Simmons comes out of the water why the
one she gave undersea oil field these
are just breath mints this is the key to
stopping the C virus it's Jake it's
gonna get bro could you check and see
has any units near the oil field I'm
gonna send him a quick bro oil make sure
he's okay missile that is a missile
Chris we're just outside of tachi why
[Music]
the people looting with the soldiers
right there
what if the missile the screen set LOL
jk and then just left that's like what
the Joker would do he have a missile
that like shut up a flag that says
[Music]
if there's a shot this live in Beijing
it's amazing it's gonna turn everyone
into C virus soldiers zombie
[Music]
[Applause]
we gotta be way faster than that run run
run girl run
friend girl
[Music]
we did it there's five chapters per
silver [ __ ] me damn it be
oh wait mine looks cooler than yours
that's why all right
how long is that thing I want I want to
play a little longer yeah you gotta we
could do a whole another episode see
where we're at this was happening no I
don't want quit okay got it
hey that's not called starting fire I'm
little too damn politically correct
nation changing it from star to option
[Music]
oh right we can buy stuff I'll tell you
what I'm not gonna do I'm not gonna
upgrade melee again god damn it
purchase upgrades I want to let me um no
maybe you're dumb oh I have 15,000 I
thought it said $157 oh yeah that's why
quick reload yeah anyway to item drop
increase - I'm getting enough equip all
set I want to get rid of melee level -
but they don't melee people enough where
are these locked can i unlock them is
that how it works yeah that's got it I'm
like I like the song Rocksteady
[Music]
shooting wild removes your targeting
site but increases your firepower it's
pretty dangerous stuff there Tex
I'm gonna save my points but I am gonna
increase oh wait I can't accuse my [ __ ]
you win this round all right I'm done
there wasn't anything good that I wanted
not with the amount of points that I had
this wasn't a very good points episode
for me where we know China - just a
country what China -
my job description I need you to rescue
two hostages punch them went the
windshield of his GF vision Cheri
Burcham
crap I need that
Wesker I hate that copy my way
good thanks I love you
along
[Music]
Sheri and Jake Nietzsche oh don't let
him down
it's the saddest copy of all time okay
your parents find the survivors and get
the hell out of here grandparents your
dog and your goldfish died do you copy
of the C virus in the gasps looks like
I'm moving in to search for surviving
and I stop showing us that skyscraper
why hey you wanna help is he supposed to
talk to us
hey come on
give us a guy give us one of those guns
I feel like that guy in town didn't talk
to us was he supposed to talk to him
he's also saying obvious things like
don't go into gas how was it not getting
in here in this building in Windows I
was an emblem back there what's it like
oh [ __ ] storm I don't think that's the
Hat where oh I see there's boxes
everywhere this boutique was stockpiling
ammo and lingerie
oh [ __ ] we need to go up really it's
that fast that's what the gas does hero
you did get greedy you were looking at
all the design no I'm going back okay
where's the food cart I want to try this
on I finally go come on dude all right
come on Steven was that one of him I
said stay back I thought he said Steven
that's way better
Wow
we'll save you Steven bah oh [ __ ] you
man like obviously we were here
cool good see work pray open this pray
and pray Steven I didn't even get a
chance to like hang out with that guy
got eaten by zombies but damn is he good
at pool Oh am I doing this no I'm just a
head missile I can look around in the
car can you can't you see me happening
where there's a hole or deep cover you
know I've never seen you I might have
told you a story before but my friends
saw the happening in theaters and he
thought that the twist at the end was
that they were filming a movie because
the acting was so bad he thought it was
a it was like a thing where the twist
would be that they were they were making
a movie and that's why they're acting
was so bad but their acting was just bad
yeah
yes should have ended careers I'm sorry
is this just a passive thing it's one of
those things where you said it like
builds tension and stuff
how can you see where we're going Steven
lieutenant Steven Steven heartbreak
thank you purchase I think this is
supposed to be kind of emotional it's
supposed to be why I don't know any of
these people know that's I'm saying
about these people can you turn the AC
on what's on the radio around here run
run Rudolph um-- the band called yes
they're amazing echo team come in come
in come in so wait what happened to that
guy that like saved us he's like hanging
out in there or what
hey hey use your blinker I can't let the
gas truck
it does it it's hell on my sex life
that's why I got into this business
[Music]
oh this is the beginning
right
[Music]
oh god we have to do this again and then
do that just go right to the boss fight
they wouldn't dare
Mikey hey Oh Oh Mikey psyche look
different
thanks aide this way okay
I've got a feeling things are about to
get worse ha damn it you ever get that
feeling that sometimes things are going
to get worse before they get better
that's the feeling that I got right now
you checking his pulse I don't know why
it made me harass prompted me sir this
definitely is the beginning but how am I
not injured right it's like we went back
in time and then altered reality
hey wait gonna play Annette why is she
using the button there's a herb in here
if you need it I'm up we're gonna have
to fight that boss but I'm [ __ ] rich
in ammo like considering previous balls
[Music]
considering like previous systems in
this made you like I don't know consider
ammo so much and this one just throws
ammo at use game yeah like I've never
been stressed about ammo and that's such
a cool thing to be afraid of right it's
like they gave me all this stuff oh my
god how many times you could kick a
certain time silicate I asked myself
that every day
see it's the beginning why are they I
don't know please let me stop what
direction is growing the cars again who
did this
we like actually did the episode one
take them take them stick
all right she's off the car wait nope
[ __ ]
nope
is it the other way No
oh it's gonna break away that dryer got
it right the thing that we couldn't do
we're dumb
airplane mic he picks us up and then but
we were already here for them that would
have been on fire by now it's true
we have to watch this again oh I'm
controlling it desperate I forgot to
I think I'm gonna die
hey hey classic Mikey remember that
beefing intro ended at that boss fight
like why did that come out that guy come
out to shoot play a suicide mission
father I see oh [ __ ]
that was so [ __ ] close I wasn't ready
I just wanted to hang
[Music]
hey Mike yeah you guys hanging out with
me guess you ever get a sense of things
I play AE I'm dead hey time to flat
circle it's all happy to get him before
remember when I flew a plane you're
gonna shoot great really probably it's
just the beginning of the game they're
just making me redo the plane again just
like we do no dude yeah you're gonna
shoot no I'm asking you are we redoing
this yeah no I mean like the whole thing
yeah I mean like yeah we're getting back
to
sorry what I'm trying to say is did we
accidentally just restart this campaign
No
I don't think
like what if we're just playing this
campaigning that'd be pretty funny
because this is the same I just can't
think of a reason why they would do that
they think it's cool the tarantino i
hope to keep making you play it so now
we got the bustling it's that scene from
Jurassic Park three
they look angry don't move
freeze
you all right yeah how is this still our
campaign no yeah we get we got the boss
fight coming up yes what yes do not rush
me I'm reloading all my guns so I can
see if I can [ __ ] pick this [ __ ] up
get over here get over here Oh remember
the joke I made about that thing the
penis yeah something doesn't feel right
who would erect such a monument in such
a place he's quit saying erect
I'm already
they're good sir
he's too perfect searching for a partner
as in like two other people playing for
cherry and Jake's part know that what is
this Simmons yeah that's my said oh my
god I know this is only a campaign but
it honest and truly feels like the whole
game we've got another campaign or to
use she's paid me she's like I know I
told you on the phone
[Music]
[Applause]
is he gonna turn into the machines and
beast again
[Music]
hope you got friends on the other side
no one's gonna miss you here
[Music]
explosive [ __ ]
ah that's [ __ ] dinosaur decided that
there's a helicopter rotating around
it's just like that scene from Jurassic
Park 3
listen the t-rex may or may not have
like hurt me
this is a strange gym wait where did he
do [ __ ] - you're right he's a [ __ ]
over there oh there's he gotta get him
up um Peter made it wait he's gone by
this expose barrel okay listen well no
oh yeah his eyes eyes right there
I got it got it I got it
great job I know [ __ ] about no are suing
our - I'm gonna shoot him in this be
something
but he's near the giant dick but if he
is a tyrant like a triceratops now
the shotgun worked well he opened his
eye and I walked
listen I think he ate me
no I got you
with the fun I hope you like them
stationary kudamon is freaking i hey you
think we should shoot him in a time gee
I wonder what we should well we should
aim for Judith dick
he's driving in a circle
what is this place
should talk we good yeah sure yeah
okay I got a someone's gotta get off and
go ahead open everybody but he got some
food
let's go faster must go faster are we
dead
[Music]
hi come on shrink shrink eat faster
oh crap
oh you got him I think I did
he's shrinking get him okay
[ __ ] him up [ __ ] you you douche of days
sure his peepee
okay I'll punch his face face gonna
punch him through me just shotgun him in
the mouth
oh this is so lame is he dead dragon
thanks chef
the damn
he has it Wow all right I'm down go on
down Oh
circle me please you got it sorry r1 r1
r1 all right got it
I was kicking here's that here's a min
oh my god you're so and the way
what happened did he fly up who's next
to be
he's throwing a car
thought you should know
okay he hit me with me
[ __ ] you you're so dumb Frankie get him
finish hey daddy
I feel like I should have worked by now
I couldn't agree she's still going come
on die
Mike doing something wrong honestly no
feel like it's time based but like
what is your problem
are you alive
back in the car maybe
she was I is all I can hello we like
have our guns ready just in case like he
we can take him alive yeah it's like
we're seen eat it
oh that's wrong it's nothing it's Taco
Tuesday let's go oh [ __ ] it is today
isn't it is Taco Tuesday I always forget
it's too late all right what say we call
it there doesn't yeah that was good okay
I think we'll finish the campaign next
time I think don't boilers stop that
no the elevator works
we know that the elevator works now you
can't ignore it it's going all the way
oh she's more than a friend
spoilers I'm leaving well see you next
week the elevator blows up on the
penultimate penultimate they're jumping
jump off the elevator stopped at you'll
see you next